so we got a special surprise for you
this one we found the cheat codes and we
put our gameshark in and and put the
skate three discs on top of the
gameshark disc because that's how cds
anyone even know what a gameshark is
these days that died a long game genie
game genie was no gameshark was all 64
oh that's right man
that was my game shark cartridge was
this we got that Japanese only addition
to the aftermarket dolphin it didn't
quite fit you could buy it and if you
shaved off some of the edges you could
wedge an n64 cartridge on yeah if you
cut the n64 cartridge in the shape of a
disc and you shoved it in there it
wouldn't work and it burst into flames
they were two dollars each and you could
you couldn't remove the game once you'd
put it on there so you had to buy one
for each year anyway we just went into a
made-up recap of not history that's ever
happened they're not even holding it
right oh it's attached to your thing
this is the one where the voice actually
does come into play you were just
geniusly fortunate exactly yeah begot
the Force One description for markiplier
the first thing that people think of
genius news oh oh now you're gonna
actually be good to kill let's kill him
oh my gosh I swear to god they're mini
it's hard to even remember their mini
I'm gonna go down here suffering
succotash and you're gonna need to drink
some water after this I got my okay this
is not like sparkles you don't know I
mean
well but I'm gonna call you Jordan
anyway please comment like comment
subscribe as you think about markiplier
is not impression of you so just like
you there's another one over there
Ottoman down I'm just gonna add purpose
like them and then look away he's gone
there you go mark nope nope I come here
God do you really does look like a
linear Oh
come here [ __ ] you killed him just Oh
mark there's a whole bunch of crap
behind that kid that's not his floor
back there there's like trash and like
rusty nails my spine you know that so
there's I'm telling you man the game
does not want you to leave the game area
exploration is not a part of this oh did
he die yeah he's very hot oh man I'm
dead was it that Holly
oh my can't get off go in no no no I got
this okay we are doing just to make it
look me look as good as possible like I
say everything I say just cut to the
same clip of you going don't pander to
me
Oh
oh my god oh my god wait Marc Marc I
can't go any higher but we can use this
we can use this technology [ __ ] oh my
god then it's such an interesting
exercise [ __ ]
no but this isn't a good place for that
you should do that on a high place
already that's how we can get up to a
building dude just so we're clear let's
recap you can even show the clip
wait you should while you're in here you
should set dumpsters on top of yourself
berry-berry yeah I wish we had Barry I
love Harry no but yeah yeah Marc stack a
dumpster on yourself
that's no big great impression to me you
got there I fits with my other is there
anything taller you could do this with I
think this one's the only one that will
work because it's like got shallow
bottom that I like well okay just kill
myself
wait I have to get in the I know just I
was gonna I was gonna I was gonna I was
gonna go just let me say whatever you're
about to do so your skateboard for
what's about to happen
nope I I don't know why I question oh I
know why
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh I don't even know if that place to me
this is the least interesting glitch
anyone's ever for like 40 feet no I
never gotten there well let's see if
that marker actually placed oh it just
got it go to marker where I the clerk to
the marker go to the marker Oh yourself
Oh God everything went sepia oh my god
tasers and whatnot oh god if afro guy
comes by he's going to chase you down
instantly zombies come here I'm sure
it's fine it's not fine you're a little
kid in a zombie apocalypse wait now that
you entered oh yeah whether we should
take our clothes off that is exactly
that is not even actually what happened
which is no exaggeration and that's
honestly downplaying it and it got so
intense in there that Ryan actually
started bleeding why how you better run
from me I'm coming for you son of a
what's that sound oh my god okay I broke
it I'm just rubbing into the side of it
[Music]
[Laughter]
a big one no no [ __ ] you should include
that voice I might end this on a big one
[ __ ] that it's the ending like there's
nothing else besides that
[Music]